hi everyone Black Widow is finally
getting her own solo movie Marvel has
ordered a script for Scarlett
Johansson's long time female Avenger
president so many questions what Marvel
storylines could be adapted to the
screen
what other Avengers could appear with
her no no this is not about co-stars
this is about Black Widow being the sole
star of the story
finally finally we're gonna dig into
this but first we're uh we just wanna
welcome you to new rock stars news this
is our weekly deep dive into all the
biggest stories this week hello
so in addition of like what we're gonna
talk about the possibility of black
panther leading the Avengers in the
future we're gonna talk about being the
leader of The Avengers hood we're gonna
get into some details that came out
about venom and some details that came
out about an interesting cake we're
gonna wake the cake we're gonna do a
cake down we're gonna go back for second
helpings on this cake well I'm Eric Voss
these karol hands joining me in this
nerdy roundup or it is me Sam basher and
I've been gone too long
I made a choice okay let's get started
with our top story guys marvel's
announcement this week that they had
hired a screenwriter to produce a script
for a black widow solo film yes now this
doesn't mean that the movie has been
officially greenlit it's just a positive
step forward I don't see them turning
back now I mean Scarlett Johansson has
been a huge movie star for like a decade
now it's been a long time coming but the
writer of this film is Jack Schaeffer
that she's she's very new she wrote but
she wrote a really little gem rom-com
you can catch on Netflix it's called
timer I just has a nice benefit very low
budget so don't expect a lot from it but
a nice benefit to me you need a little
sci-fi in your rom-com tiny a little bit
of sci-fi this happy version of the
black mirror of how much time do you
have
with this person oh yeah yes yes she's
very much new Cooper and that seems to
be kind of her style she also was known
for like a blacklist favorite that's a
a list of popular scripts that pass
around Hollywood it's called the shower
it's about an alien invasion that takes
place during a baby shower that's
supposed to be coming out in the next
three years cool
there's also filled with baby babies and
a couple of things that you may be aware
of a project called nasty women it's a
female version of dirty rotten
scoundrels and then she also wrote the
Disney short olaf's frozen adventure
which I know in my opinion it was a lot
better than yeah you shouldn't put a
20-minute movie in front of a movie that
you want but I feel like kids are gonna
watch it every year every Christmas yeah
I got to watch cocoa without it and I
was very thankful but I'm sure good for
that's great
well now it's still incredibly early I
think we should discuss the possible
plot of this movie now these are just
our best guesses based on the rumors
that we've heard and the most popular
black widow storylines from the comics
they might know another way but we if we
had a bet on it this would be our picks
for the most likely ways that they will
go this is research most likely these
are the most popular black would coolest
and not just most popular most adaptable
to film like you could see this being a
good film okay so first there's the
itsy-bitsy spider storyline from the
comics in that story a young Russian spy
named Yelena Bulova targets Natasha
hoping to take away the title of Black
Widow from her it's extremely popular
and well done kind of kitschy that could
introduce another female lead into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so you could
see them casting any young upstart to
join this pantheon of players manning
does that uh does that character play a
bigger role I'm because I'm not familiar
with that that character she does and
there's a couple different issues in
mini-series that she comes back and
there's one called breakdown where they
end up kind of switching identities so
she is kind of a recurring character who
could be interesting they actually kind
of adapted a version of it for the TV
show alias but it's one of the best
storylines in the show and then they
actually do switch there's like a body
double anyway yeah well circuit Marvel
could be considered adapting parts of
the 80's web of intrigue storyline in
which six world-class assassins target
Natasha to keep her busy while a
doppelganger of her plots to kill
Nick Fury whoa different doppelganger
different doppelganger not not uh but uh
this is another huge action story line
that you know would allow Scarlett
Johansson to show off her acting skills
cuz presumably she would play this
look-alike as well and she's I mean like
we've this doesn't even need to be said
but just I'd be awesome to see well
really really well choreographed fight
scene yes because like from actually
right when she started she's just blown
us away yeah there's also a really
popular storyline called name of the
rose where like it many black widows
story she gets labeled an enemy of the
state and has to clear her name
what's cool about this one is there's a
lot of supporting cameos including Iron
Man and Wolverine and now that Disney
own so far as possible for x-men
characters like Wolverine to appear in
these stories so who knows which now
they have so many assets to pull from it
I feel like we can see all kinds of
people pop up in this story but let's
take this into our pitch room like using
these plot details are really any a
dream scenario you guys would like to
see your previous film that collects
service and inspiration
let's pitch what you want this Blackwood
a movie to look like I'll go mostly
because I all forget it all of it ok
cool so we have Black Widow the best
version of Black Widow is Black Widow
actually playing undercover in my
opinion I really liked that element of
the character and I feel like they never
do enough with it instead she just is
like a gymnast fighter that does that
one move like it's an awesome takedown
to flip so yeah but she's actually so
much more capable I mean she's like kind
of an inspiration for alias and
characters like that insult is another
good example or Black Widow might have
inspired red Sparrow which will be
coming to him but in my version it's
it's a similar storyline that she's
labeled an enemy of state but it's
because the president United States is
just dead he's been killed he's been
murdered and DNA evidence links it back
to her the mild amount of Records that
they had to supply its you know to oh
it's it's Romanov again so they're they
label are an enemy of the state but at
the same time she knows it wasn't her
but there she does know that it's a
former Russian agent that had went
through the same training as her and so
she starts trying to find out which one
it is and exposing them so the old
program activates all of the Russian
agents who are still currently in the
United States living secret undercover
law
to kill her and it becomes kinda like
The Bourne Identity where all of the
other ones that have the same level of
training are activated and trying to
kill him specifically they're all trying
to kill her specifically the big thing
that she has to do is one she has to
stay undercover because both the FBI and
everyone's looking for her but also so
are the Russian so she had to play a
bunch of different roles bunch of
different costumes and stay in hiding
while they hunt her and they're like the
best at doing that kind of hiding so
they know how she would hide and like
where her hideout to be and whatever and
all that stuff it's kind of like how I
feel like the Civil War should have done
Captain America storyline because that's
how it is in the comics and I love that
going underground having to like kind of
be disguise all the time it plays out a
little bit like Winter Soldier too in
terms of like the tone and then the
crazy thing is the DNA evidence it's
linked through mitochondrial DNA which
means that the only other person that
potentially could have killed the
president is her mother
whoa mama Black Widow for Parks and Rec
though as well I just watched that
recently so I like the idea of having to
go up against the Russians and the
United States because I think that
really works for their character the
only thing is I'm scared of it I could I
was thinking that too that it would
tread kind of the same territory that
Winter Soldier did a little bit of
having a whole government go right down
which it no I mean it's my fate I think
Civil War has my favorite like moments
but with Winter Soldier is like the
tightest best thriller that the MCU has
been able to make so more that I'd be
very happy but I think what could make
this movie really really special when
well I haven't like picked like an
antagonist for because I think any
number of government agencies would be
interesting like I think it'd be really
interesting if we focused in London and
like we got to actually like see like
mi6 and like whatever like British
heroes that we want to like play around
with I think that'd be really cool if we
got x-men maybe you could do Excalibur
and you could do like a dumbed down
version of that but anyways what I think
that would make this movie so special as
if you did it stylize and I kind of
think like a Wes Anderson but less
pastel and you know kind of like like a
pop-up book more like solid colors light
effects no Holly yeah
so a lot of like center I want to get a
lot of action shots where she's the
center of the frame she's the center of
her film and you get like contrast with
like red and white in black and like it
you get to kind of play with these
colors like of course Marvel already
does that with their shows like the best
example is the first six episodes of
daredevil season 1 like how light
there's yellows and browns you get a
little hints of red and black and I
think if you do a lot of that with her
it would make her movie really really
special and I know we're getting like a
ton we have had an atomic blonde red
sparrows coming out and salt and stuff
but like it sucks because these movies
don't really like they kind of for me
they haven't met my expectations of what
I expect like what they could do with
this exactly like I met John wick is
like the closest I've ever been like to
be happy with this this type of genre
but I think if you add a lot of style to
her because if you look at the most
recent she had an amazing run with I'm
blanking Oh Mark Waid wrote the run and
Chris Sam knee he did the art and it's a
lot of pastels and kind of like this
Jetsons 1960s era design and it's a lot
of just like solid red just her like the
silhouette of her face and white and
it's like this would be so cool if you
really nailed this kind of color kind of
like um the intro to any Bond film with
the the gun barrel following him I think
that would be really helpful for her it
would get a lot of film nerds on board
and I think this movie could really
write Marvel or put them on a map in a
different way it's a movie called lucky
number Slevin which is like a stylized
action but it actually is an action
comedy which which could be fun too your
thing would lend itself very much to be
setting a different time to yes I think
80s would be really interesting it would
be tough cuz like you you could do an
eighties feel to this movie and make it
like maybe early two-thousands or
something like that but um it would be
really cool but it was technically maybe
a few journalists yeah yeah maybe with
their phones were crazy yeah I uh it was
interesting he mentioned comedy with
teetee he's asked about like what would
a black widow a movie what should it
look like and he wanted it to be more
comedic he thought that because her
storylines and her Baxter always seemed
so dour and serious I think it'd be more
fun to like explore a light-hearted
approach personally she does get super
depressed hard not to step on it but
like when we got into Avengers
- it was like yes they took away my
reproductive organs and I was like whoa
not that that didn't add something to
her but I was like give her a win every
once in a while like this is rough but I
would like that also Hawkeye would be I
know that's always been the pitches them
together right but they do work really
well together also her and Bucky as well
and I think the red star in his arm and
the red in her hair and everything would
make a very good poster yeah I could see
that uh I mean you'd mention Winter
Soldier and I think for me what worked
really well is it had it was the first
time I remember in the MCU feeling like
a different genre like it felt like an
old-school espionage thriller espionage
we're like the spy angle and the
government conspiracy was kind of the
the driving plot point and I think they
could go even further down that road
bringing something into the 80s I would
love to see I don't need an origin story
for Black Widow like I feel like I like
kind of a teen flashback scene some
flashbacks to it I would love an entire
because I'm really into them in the show
the Americans on FX which is so good oh
it's so fantastic somehow it's like gone
five seasons and people still haven't
yeah it's fantastic it's set it suddenly
80s with two Soviet spies who are
embedded as Americans hi posing as
Americans with the family trying to
undercut the the government operations
and and enact during the Cold War during
the Reagan era Cold War but they do
flashbacks at least in the first season
and I think throughout - their time
rising up through the KGB in the 60s and
the different mentors they had and the
way they met and we're kind of
programmed to act like a married couple
I think there could be something to that
something similar to that kind of feel
with black widow storylines set in the
80s seeing the people who trained her
and they betrayed her because I think it
is interesting when we saw and in Winter
Soldier how we learned not to trust
shield and we not to learn learn not to
trust big government and I think that's
even further involved when people like
look into the KGB how many of their
assets they burned how many of the
how many of them they just weren't given
basic information that was wrong and
they were just put on the suicide
mission I'd like to see Natasha's
reaction to that world and how she
escaped it I'd be really cool I just had
this idea that like I mean they talked
about that she came from a facility that
trained women like this and they
definitely like having like one of the
other women that wants to be the new
Black Widow I think it'd be okay to play
with a bunch of them like as in like you
get this moment where you know there's a
woman out there that's doing this and
you kind of get a spoilers for Arkham
City that came out like 10 years ago now
but like that there's more than one and
that's what the reveal is that you know
there's another one there's a copycat
but then you get into a room where like
Natasha is talking one-on-one with this
other girl and it's like trying to talk
her out of like the red-room training
and like she maybe has keywords for
herself to talk herself out of like this
brainwashing but then you realize that
she's not the only person in the room
and like there's six other women there
and they've all that's why this girl has
been so efficient at taking down like
these parts of the government or other
governments all around the world or spy
agencies you're like and I want to see
an action set piece where like basically
what would be an example of it like it's
you always get like the group of
soldiers to go into like the
supernatural threat and like now we
could take them down you just like oh no
we can see the full capabilities of what
this thing can do but you get it with
like six women just like oh yeah yeah
and they're like they're swinging from
the ceiling doing like the next
Natasha's like the general later I mean
you could get that but I mean like her
trying to figure out a way to actually
like take down that Decker
yeah that exact know is that that
group's the one that's like still
ingrained and set like someone's taking
control of whatever their programming is
and she has to figure out a way to like
she doesn't want to kill them because
she knows what they've been through and
like they know she knows they can get
better and so you get like a lot of
heart right your idea should meet my
idea and they should combine so that all
those people that are coming after are
those those women that were milling
widows also I think you would like
season seven of Buffy yeah for all the
potential Slayers get activated all
around the world that's cool
I should watch Buffy I've seen angel
should watch Buffy well let us know what
another black what a movie you'd like to
see whether it's a some kind of
adaptation of a story that we've seen
before or something from the comics or
some kind of new way that you would like
to see her expand the universe of the
MCU and what other people that maybe
you'd like to see your team up with or
would you like to just see her be in a
movie and great new characters Hawkeye
Mockingbird that anybody from shielded
they wanted to pull over like baby
shield yeah you could I mean it would
make a lot of sense yeah but for now
let's move on to this week's trivia
question hmm which it's going to be
keeping things
Black Widow related Wow okay so our
question what alias did Natasha Romanov
used when she first met Tony Stark when
she was embedded as a legal notary in
his company in Iron Man 2 she apparently
used a fake name that he later called
out as BS I'm also doing that re-watch
watts watch 1mc movie a week until
Avengers infinity war so I'm watching
Hulk tomorrow I'm very good
as we write down answers just to you
know keep you guys entertained I'm going
to the screen behind me of the two of
the media I'm gonna I guess rewrite the
dialog between Tony and etosha here and
likes everything my fan fiction version
in this moment cool cool they're right
inside is where I can't really say what
I want to say to you right now because
peppers right over there
but I want you to quit so that you and I
can explore what we're meant to explore
in eight years that's gonna end your
career because you'll find out how time
is up and I don't like your eye line
right now Stark I'm where range fan
fiction it's people charged in Haven
writing down anything that sounds good
well tweet your rage at me for my fan
fiction and it seems like we have some
answers now now as always we will reveal
this exciting answer at the end of the
episode you can leave your guesses in
the comments and then we'll have to do
the thing where we trust you that you
didn't look it up yeah everything ever
saw in YouTube comments was freestyle
rapping on top of the dome as decided by
our judges will do our sign off goodbyes
at the in the video and do whatever you
know dumb voice or bid or amazing new
character they're trying out and I tank
I you know gave you a little taste of my
cowhand character maybe he'll come back
we'll see feet are in other news wrap-up
headlines and be hilarious on the spot
I'm great at that sounds great cool
moving on moving on well folks black
panther has been breaking records for
first day ticket pre-sales setting up to
be one of the biggest Marvel movies ever
meanwhile many have speculated that
Avengers infinity war while also looking
like a massive blockbuster hit of course
will actually be pretty bleak for many
of its characters with the old guard
like Iron Man Tony Stark Captain America
Steve Rogers and Thor perhaps on the
chopping
marvelous signaled that the second of
the two upcoming Avengers movies will
signal a major turning point into phase
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
suggesting that one or more of these
front men may die now if Black Panther
ends up being the smash hit it's looking
to be could that set him up to lead the
adventures into the next era
could he be the next Iron Man I thought
we'd look at this black panther Iron Man
parallel by comparison what qualities do
to chala and Tony Stark's share that
could poise a black panther to be the
new face Marvel the way Iron Man has
been first thing I thought we'd look at
is maybe if you look at it they have
similar stories both are sort of
privileged sons having to earn their
position to build on their father's
legacy now you could talk about T'Challa
having a slightly different sort of
privilege than Tony Stark did but both
of them are kind of heir apparents to
these huge empires and their way they're
very influential like now like for
Wakanda becoming a bigger part of the
international community but also he's a
he's a big problem like that's a bit he
made weapons of mass destruction like he
needs to like come to terms with that so
ya know they were very similar and
actually despite them being both heirs
apparent is actually only black panther
who is really in an experienced
leadership role as part of his taking
over of his dynasty where he's a leader
of men by blood and also politically and
then Tony Stark is kind of like thrust
into a leadership role when it's like
good maybe that's why some things have
gone wrong yeah I think it both cases
it's it just shows how you can never
take anything for granted in their
stories right like even though they are
presumed successors to the Marvel comic
titles we know it's interesting to see
these men have to earn these positions
the way that Tony Stark after he left
his exile or his captivity had to come
back and he still had to wrestle control
of his company from his former boss or
his former colleague and the way that
child is gonna it looks based off the
trailers gonna have to wrestle his
throne away from the other rivals within
the rival tribes and Wakanda
was awesome that's I'm so excited and
all I wanted to bring up if he did lead
you could get a lot of mileage out of
what it would mean for a king to run a
global strike force and like god that's
a huge problem like that doesn't like in
in my mind I'm like oh my god that's
amazing I'm captain marvel they'll fly
around whatever and it's like no a king
invading like if they went into China
like that would be a huge problem yeah
Aquaman's story yeah yeah yeah there's
that line in the trailer for Black
Panther where he goes like what we
decide here what we do here will affect
the entire world like there are global
implications for what seems to be a
pretty intimate conflict Tony Stark
recognized the global responsibility he
had an Iron Man you know he's been
creating these arms that he seems shown
up and fired back at the troops that he
made them for and back in himself and
the way that T'Challa realizes whoever
controls this technologically superior
nation in Wakanda could use that power
not just to maintain their isolationist
state stance but could use it
aggressively and declare war on the rest
of the world which seems like would be a
claim in an agenda made by some of these
rivals to his positions so it's
recognizing with great power comes great
responsibility common threat there but
could be interesting in this new way of
when to pull the punch you know both
cases but I think it's also interesting
just start a base level to look at their
suit and tech like both the more super
tech suits with fun cutting-edge
technologies it's just really fun to see
in action scenes now I'll say that the
Iron Man suit is probably unparalleled
in terms of what its actual tech is that
said it's technically more destructible
than by Panther suit it is I I know you
you were talking to camera wasn't
looking my way but I'm just like looking
at the all the detail and all the
craftsmanship in Black Panthers mask
it's just so cool I love and I love that
they're introducing that it's like a
like nanites like that can grow over his
body right that's a pretty abundant
Iranian weave that can like grow and
stretch it's hard to tell how exactly it
works and maybe from the necklace collar
that he wears and it kind of grows out
from that or someone suggested it could
be based on the what is it the
bleeding-edge armor from the comics that
it's like well
actually would be a better fit even
though that's ripping off I meant it but
it's always cool but also having Wakanda
as his essentially research labs and in
terms of his tech a lot more efficient
than Tony doing everything himself you
ever notice that like all Tony's things
are like just Tony
yeah we don't he don't sleep you don't
sleep mm-hmm I think that's they've
established Leticia Wright's character
in Black Panther she's playing his
sister Cherie who's kind of like the cue
to his James Bond she's just working
away in this what Condon lab molding
vibranium into new different weapons and
suit and armor stuff so and she's been
compared to like a - Tony Stark in terms
of her brilliance and her an engineering
prowess so it it be conceivable that a
lot of the cool stuff that you've seen
Tony Starks armor do you could see in
Black Panthers armor in terms of its
weaponry and its capabilities and also
in terms of its like inner processing
unit and the way it communicates like
there was a shine in the black panther
trailer where you see Sheree driving a
car Colin must show off and it looks
like it's using the same kind of hollow
technology that his suit has it looked
amazing I want to see that car yeah real
bad oh yeah it's kind of like that weird
monopoly car that Ben Affleck drew drove
and sooo bad Justice League yeah sooo
badly the sewer bat but I think like on
a more thematic level interesting
parallel for me is both are these kind
of fantasy badasses that we want to see
that are products of the time that they
came up in so Ironman was kind of this
what-if response to the messy
frustrating wars that we got into in the
Middle East like what would happen if we
just had a quick morally responsible fix
to this you know and then Black Panther
looks like it's gonna be that kind of
what-if response to her current society
where you know African Americans are
very much oppressed in society but what
if there was a nation that existed where
they were the dominant class and let's
see this kind of after a futurist
perspective of what would happen if they
were allowed to technologically succeed
beyond the United States beyond the
United States
right of course yeah of course but like
imagine if they had you know there's
this essay called what is it germs guns
and steel where they looked at why
European societies became dominant in
global history and it's just because
there was almost this kind of lucky
perfect storm of you know why they were
able to technologically succeed and in
the Black Panther storyline they look at
what if a vibranium meteorite crashed
there and and why how would they be able
to farm this metal and be able to use it
to build a society that is more
technologically advanced than anything
we've seen in our real-world timeline so
in both cases they're kind of these
what-if responses to real world events
and I think that made Iron Man super
popular in the late 2000s or in the late
I guess in the way that it could make
Black Panthers super popular in 2018 and
beyond what do you guys make especially
this week yeah this week I mean not to
get political with with it just to
remind you though you know the president
was reportedly said something about the
value of immigrants from Africa and more
specific than that and Haiti but versus
you know Norwegians right and and
whatever you feel about that the what he
is definitely tapping into is the
perception of the history of these
different places and I love that idea
though of like what if it was like
they're given a almost like a secret
weapon right and just like skip over all
history all perception is just like oh
damn it's kind of like when Superman the
heads on it a little bit which it's kind
of like oh the game changed right yeah
and I think it was the the main actor
who was playing T'Challa thank you he
spoke about how he they created the
accent and how it was supposed to have
no European ties to the yang sandwich
I'm like that's crazy cool like that's
such a cool idea
yeah to add to the accident I know it
that must be really difficult since he
created something that doesn't exist or
he and his language coaches created
something that doesn't exist yeah I'm
just really impressed to see how they
taught the other actors how to do that
right like it's kind of like when all
the Amazons had
coppy gal gadot's accent cuz maybe no
one else to do it was like like yeah you
guys are gonna just have an Israeli
accent now and it's like that's what
that mascara sounds like yeah we got it
in this and some of our breakdowns but
the accent they used at least in Civil
War that they're now using in Black
Panther is I forget my problem is
pronunciation but it's Xhosa it's it has
that click it's a South African dialect
that was used by Nelson Mandela and
spoken by millions of people in South
Africa but all of the cultural elements
that they're trying to use a black
panther are native African as opposed to
European or African American they're
trying to go back to the source they're
using a lot of Nigerian letters in
submit e alphabet there it looks like
they're using that to base the new what
content alphabet and a lot of a
costuming and wardrobe are based on
African tribes we went into this in our
recent breakdown so they're all
everything you see on screen is trying
to be native African to try to show what
rather than like how things have been
changed as they've evolved in African
Diaspora which you absolutely should
research this has been a huge learning
experience for me just like researching
things for this videos for these videos
that we've made out but like it's been
fascinating to see the research that
they've tried to do to make this a truly
authentic world that is grounded in real
African cultures I've got a quick
question for you guys just how would how
do you think the rest of the team would
respond to Black Panther as their leader
yeah I mean like do a lot of them know
that about them like yeah it's kind of
unknown other than just so I mean been a
wild card introduction right I think
it's gonna depend how things go and
black panther and in the infinity war
the first film that's coming out because
it depends who's gonna survive this
right like if the new lineup is composed
of people like Doctor Strange and Black
Widow and Peter Parker then yeah I could
see them looking at someone who is the
king of a technologically advanced
nation as someone who is someone worth
calling the shots I mean he also is kind
of in Avengers infinity war like you get
a shot of him like giving two like he's
giving orders yeah there's only one shot
where he's not leading the charge that
final shot with cap and then he's next
to him but every other shot he's leading
the army out rights whatever this these
aliens throw out there that it
complicates things that he may be a
they respect his title but his duty is
to akanda yeah and not to wear any of
the other right unless like the idea and
this and in civil war was that what
Conda is now trying to be like have a
bigger hand in the world or at least
like have a bigger presence sorry that's
the better word to pick and so the best
way to do that is to have basically I
can think of another word mascot that on
your Avengers team that everyone in the
world looks up to and it's like no he's
from a quant what Conda and so let's
let's pay more attention to that I don't
know it's like it's a good it makes
sense but also yeah you're right his
duties are to his people so it could be
a situation where he leaves the duties
of ruling the country in the hands of
someone else the way that like started
with Pepper Potts leaving the company
day-to-day operations and I think his
mom is running it right now and there's
plenty of other like we don't know how
this relationship is gonna go with
Michael B Jordans character keel monger
maybe this guy does have a legitimate
claim to the wakandan throne and yeah
whatever is other aliases who knows
there's I think there's a lot different
ways to go or it could be something
similar like I think it's worth
comparing him to Captain America who in
Avengers the first Avengers film didn't
have the same kind of strengths that
some of these their powers that the
other rivals did but they just trusted
his leadership ability and his ability
to keep calm under pressure and be able
to understand what other people's assets
were and how to deploy them I could see
T'Challa having similar wisdom and
similar common to pressure in the midst
of battle that they all eventually
respect cool what you guys think about
potentially black panther leading the
next iteration of the Avengers you
already listed off an amazing team of
Doctor Strange spider-man and black
panther and I'm like I'm I'm happy with
that throw Captain Marvel in there and
that'd be cool apps and blackbolt I'll
bring them over from the TV show I
invested my time now you all have to as
well we just got real close to doing the
Illuminati - oh yeah cool
and if you if you don't see black
panther being the one at the the top of
the chain maybe is there someone else
that you'd like to see take the reins or
one of these other characters that we
mentioned ant-man one of these comment
down below or hit us up on Twitter at
new rock stars with your thoughts thanks
guys thank you
I want ant-man to use the Avengers for
crime okay let's move on to some of the
other big news this week since-- by the
way this show does cover all the key
stuff that you need to know about but
this news is actually a little hard to
make out at first two images were
released first a look at Tom Hardy as
Eddie Brock in the upcoming venom movie
so truthfully from the comments to Tom
Hardy already arrived at set one day and
some in turn took a photo of them you
weren't gonna see venom before but also
there's a set photo of the cake and the
Avengers infinity war a wrap party guys
there's even more to these than meet the
eyes we can laugh but let's pull our
obsessive new rock stars lens out here
these pictures okay first let's look
back at this picture of Tom Hardy now on
the surface this photo seems yes kind of
lame just a shot of Tom Hardy in street
clothes so laying some bracelets or two
cool what exactly as I imagined Eddie
Brock play by Tom Hardy - right right
he's got his reporter's notebook but hey
those notes say something really
you can either zoom or enhance say when
you zoom you lose resolution it's so
dumb but we love it okay
well hit enhance enhance I'm explaining
the joke this is classic air coverage
okay
staple of the show if you look closely
you can see the life foundation written
down in his notebook so just explain the
life foundation is from the Marvel
spider-man comics there are society of
elites who believe that the world would
be destroyed in nuclear holocaust and
they took various dark measures to
survive it and plan for their utopian
society thereafter now in the venom
lethal protector series they kidnapped
venom and extracted five symbiote
children from his DNA to create soldiers
to protect their new society those
included scream phage riot Lasher and
agony now venom and spider-man had to
end up teaming up together to defeat
them all we'll see how this affects with
the news that carnage would be the
villain of this movie maybe they're like
retconning Carnage's origin to have the
light foundation behind his attachment
well they could definitely still do an
offshoot from his symbiote right we
could have a lot more villains it could
be carnage and and those are people who
lead his way to uncovering how carnage
is another symbiote don't add more yeah
also those five like I know there's fans
out there of those fight but it's fine
if they don't it's fine don't pop up
there's also toxin there's also
anti-venom there's like I'm it's a
million more that you can do those five
are fine for not being in a movie for
the next like couple years venom three
we'll get those and we'll be everyone be
happy about it yeah but that makes sense
for carnage like honestly off the top of
my head I can't remember I all I know is
that carnage was Venom's like they the
symbiote made a little baby and it went
to Cletus Kasady because they shared a
cell and that's what it isn't and they
they joined and they made right they
found him in prison and that's yeah and
this you could just take Cletus or
whatever character you want to play
carnage I you guys can calm down it's
okay if it's not clear it's gonna be
somebody I know well a part of me was
just like they might change the name yes
like Cletus is just a slack-jawed yokel
yeah and like it's trying to be changed
and also it makes sense like you get a
prisoner you want to test out if we can
take the symbiote and give it to
somebody else and like no you can't like
it doesn't work that way and like
carnage is goes crazy and starts killing
a lot of people
yeah III could see just the light
foundation being used as like part of
his conspiracy that he's uh that he's
like under uncovering to find out like
how far his symbiote has traveled and
he's found out of this like secret
society has been actually using this
sickness that he has in his soul to
weaponize it and do horrible things with
it so he's that's how what leads him
into the story that's my guess of why
they're pulling the life foundation as
like a detail from the comics I also
heard that they were gonna pull from the
the planet the plant venom planet story
but with the Clint are like what they
are and he's like everything that'd be
kind of interesting to really
complicated when you get into that like
it's new I mean I think it's pretty
obvious that this picture tell give us
all the answers can we do a cake down
now yeah okay let's move on a second
images enhance on yesterday the Russo
brothers who directed the two upcoming
Avengers movies tweeted a picture of
this epic cake for the wrap party now
that production on both movies has ended
now just look at this when does this
stop being a cake and start being art
that is probably edible is all art
edible I've raised any paint you know
okay but if you look closely some of the
design features may include some details
for the upcoming films I can't believe
we're analyzing well these are these are
people that have been exposed to these
shoots at least Infinity Ward they
definitely know a lot more than we do
they'll be referencing some inside jokes
about how the plot will go or some of
this art that they've had to construct
on set server you're saying there's a
get a cake there's gonna be a cake in
the movie is that we were saying or this
cake is the entire plot of the film it's
what I'm it's written on the app we
don't need to see the movie we just got
a look at the cake the new rockstars
theory approach look at this it depicts
Thanos falling back as he collects his
Infinity stones he's holding the blue
space stone in one hand the green time
stone in the other at his feet as a red
reality stone on the surface beneath him
is a yellow mine stone in the purple
Power Stone and then at the bottom
corner people oh closely the edge of the
cake is the orange soul stone which we
still have yet to see in the MCU
probably gonna be in black panther we'll
see now along the middle tier are the
logos for the Avengers characters
there's whole
cap Iron Man Thor and Black Widow
presumably the locus of the other MCU
heroes line the other side to the cake
or maybe everyone else will die and
those the other and then from that tier
this is probably most interesting you
can make out 3 arms bursting out of this
cosmic field to grab the platform that
Danis is standing on the one closest to
us is Black Widow the the wrists mo
there is a signature of hers but the
other two are a bit harder to tell
there's a reddish one behind hers I'm
thinking it might be vision I would say
strange but he wears the yellow gloves
Oh vision you're right I was thinking
Ironman but there's no there like it was
and then the one in the back has claws
that are scraping the surface making me
think it's black panther's vibranium
claws the one in the very very back you
can't even see the army to see the claws
that are scraping gotcha ok now someone
suggested that these three are the ones
who might die but guys I highly doubt
Black Panther a black widow will die in
these Avengers movies sounds like Marvel
has big plans for both of their futures
although vision hmm I could see him
going down we honestly I think that they
might be twisting things because
everyone can see vision dying especially
with this so I'm thinking like also
these could be the ones that make it
right
these are the three to survive or the
three to like bring the this trio teams
up in some interesting way to go on some
mission to destabilize maybe that's like
a metaphor we can look into I don't know
what do you guys see any clues on this
cake that might tell us what about the
other arm I only see three do you see a
fourth yeah you guys see the arms and
then that one's bursting out at the
bottom look at the crystals or something
that one going up it doesn't look like
so much like an arm no the left that
looks like a pillar but just because
it's bursting out like the rest of them
it seems more important I think you tell
I think its purposes for cake physics
okay but you're right they probably
wouldn't have just done that and not
decorated that one part and they left it
at yellow cake that's right it probably
is a little bit
I thought like it was just like with the
lighting of the thing like we couldn't
really tell what it is but maybe you
guys are right it's probably maybe it's
dr. strangers club could be something
like that oh yeah if we're not like yeah
you got a good idea that this could be
just a false lead Oh or maybe the cake
designer just wanted to do those
forearms on the sledge on the spatula
someone got into this cake girl I love
the detail and anuses face and pecs and
the pecs and the pecs that they have
there they're very defined do you think
you can eat Sana's no yeah unless you
hold the entire gauntlet holding the
umbrella over the cake in the picture
like where was it I thought was run in a
studio because they have those blue
screens set up this is why would they
ever bring this cake out in the rain so
yeah those blue screens are interesting
those are the ones they actually bring
to when they shoot out in the real world
do you bring those screens up and you
block out certain things and now you can
relocate anything it happens all the
time on shows like Law & Order and this
shows like name so they don't Ragan's
flying around shoot in the middle of the
day morning add people later yeah that's
pretty cool I'm surprised that they've
said they wrapped both films already
which is very impressive I know this
could be reshoots for the next couple
months a year four years I think in
April or May when the movie comes out
I'm definitely going to want to go back
and look at this cake be good I think ya
know that in turn driving it to the set
was probably having a heart attack
because that's how do you move it
how do you get that anywhere no I for my
last job I had to transport a an apology
cake I used to work on a talk show where
they had a guest that they pissed off so
I as a PA had to drive an apology cake
and I buckled it in to my seatbelt to
make sure it didn't and then they the
person who received it tweeted saying
hey thanks for giving me a smushed cake
and I thought I was gonna get fired and
I think she just did as a joke not
realizing I was just on the show for a
week at that point and I almost got
fired for it
what if she lied she lied it was not so
much did you sit on her why did take a
slice of it but I didn't see but you
fixed the rest of it so it looked like
it was a natural smush yes don't ever
work in production okay okay you guys
tweet us questions I'm gonna fire them
at my co-host have to answer them
quickly and with no hesitation are we
ready yes Sam here we go
at this is really Sam did you write this
all right who should be casted to play
Wolverine now that Hugh Jackman is done
Taryn joel edgerton changed my name is
there's gonna be tearing as a younger
one George egg ten Edgerton Edgerton
Edgerton at that Lilly Mason wants to
know which superhero costume would you
wear purely for aesthetic reasons no
getting powers from the costume like
Iron Man's armor okay if it's summer and
we're headed into summer I want to look
like Jason Momoa as Aquaman mmm that's
like a pie this guy dream is just like
tattoos or my costume but if it's a fall
or winter or just like one of those days
where you kind of just want to be like
I'm gonna go to the coffee shop and
write or whatever Rorschach liquid
liquid cool of course when you said
summer I was like Starfire of course
it's the best one to go to the beach in
okay for me to church Oh to LA and Nora
underscore de wants to know Hogwarts
house and maybe we can all do our goats
houses okay so when I de Pottermore they
sorted me into ravenclaw
which I guess is okay and then the every
morning it was Thunderbird but I mean I
want to be in Slytherin I want to be
ambitious and power seeking and evil
I've never been sorted some of you guys
can tell me what
well your choice is taken to an account
so what would you want to be in no no no
III want to know how my personality
dictates Adobe I know that I Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw okay I'm in Gryffindor yeah
yeah now I got a novel puff first and
then I retook Yaya Gryffindor and I'm
gonna go with that one I took it because
they said they they changed they had
updated something so I took it I got
Gryffindor and when we retake it and
since she's not here mod didn't even
talk she got Slytherin I think she'll
never admit it but she did it was in the
video my Patronus was a black stallion
wow that's cool I don't know it's so
weird it's like winter rain oh yeah I'd
photo shopped it I did the 90s version
of the rock and I called him my jabronis
the rock is all of our Patrol summon
your happiest feeling that but in the
rock will show up okay next up let's
look at what we got in the pipeline for
videos coming out on the channel in this
next week
you got something coming out Iron Man's
breakdown for the MCU around you with
the release of Avengers infinity war
there's a couple fans who did the math
and they said if you watch every of MCU
movie once a week leading up to Avengers
infinity Wars release you'll have
watched everything's with star Ragnarok
included and black panther coming out in
the middle of there so that that works
out so it'll be like a week after you
can come and check out the previous
week's breakdown so Iron Man's coming up
next week I also am working on a Hulk
one right now I already started watching
it I remember liking it in theaters it
does not hold up a little bit but I'm
excited but that's really really
exciting I think also for me to get to
you know read it and watch that and also
for the fans this means we're going back
we're going to do classic MC breakdowns
of films
we weren't around for we weren't born
yet but that we've always wanted to go
back and identify all the Easter eggs
and things you might have missed so I'm
really excited for that I am it's been
very fun Ironman definitely holds up so
yeah also guys I know like in Star Wars
circles we have been waiting for a
trailer for the Han Solo movie friends
and it's alright so I was gonna talk
about this as a whole segment but it's a
super nerdy thing to even talk about we
still have nothing and we are only four
and a half months away from this movie
coming out which I know seems like a
normal amount of time for any other
movie but just for comparison the last
Jedi and brogue ones first teasers came
out eight full months before the movie
came out
the force awakens had a whopping 13
months before that but they were also
kind of reminding this in hey Star Wars
movies are coming back so I know that
like this is weird because it's not
coming out December it's coming out in
May and they won the last Jedi the way
I'm a little worried that you know maybe
this means that they don't know what
kind of footage or how they want to
frame the marketing on this so weird I
think it's got to be strategically time
January is a very frustrating time for
the studios and they also don't like
pain for during this period their
marketing budgets right they're usually
being settled and they that's why you
see in December you see so much
marketing for films and ads are actually
really expensive in theirs because
they're running out of time to spend the
money they got and in January the
budgets are kind of still being
established and they're being a little
more hesitant so it's always kind of a
dry period during January but it
definitely feels like well your movies
coming way too soon to wait yeah it
sounds like they're based on rumor Ron
Howard did tweets saying that now that
the last shot is done it will be coming
soon and some for saying it could happen
on Monday so we'll see by the time
you're watching this there may be a
trailer and yes we as soon as that
trailer comes out we will have a
breakdown for also you may have noticed
we're continuing our Game of Thrones
rewatched series but we're kind of
figuring out a new what I think is
better way of doing it we're rather than
going by episode by episode which a lot
of them are kind of forgettable in my
opinion we're just looking at specific
epic moments specific scenes not all
them are the big battle one sometimes
there's just like interesting cryptic
scenes that are just kind of left out
there for us to break down a lot of you
we just did one on the golden crown
scene from season one of is Eris's epic
amazing death and a lot of you have been
hitting us up saying oh please continue
doing the episode by episode breakdown
the reason we do that is we just can't
it's kind of a business thing we can't
justify putting so much resources for
the next 50 episodes in doing entire
theirs but we have to put a lot of work
into those yeah there's no shame in
saying those videos are by far the most
expensive videos we make the most
expensive they're creatively my most
favorite to do so I understand what
you're feeling but I will say doing this
Viserys scene I know it's new for a lot
of you I was able to go way more in
depth and thematic and explore some of
the more interesting things than that
then I would have done for sure if I had
to break down the entire episode of
episode 6 there's no way I would have
been able to make some of those
connections if I had to spend time
covering the whole episode so I love
being able to just go back to the scenes
that I really care about more than the
rest of the season even though I love
the whole series I love every episode of
this there's certain scenes that just
stand out that if I'm going to be
spending time rewatching things I gotta
pick and choose my battles and
prioritize stuff and that's it we're
always open to creative solutions of you
guys that are the diehards that were
turning up and watching those and there
weren't that many of you but if you guys
are diehard fans about the episode by
episode breakdowns
I mean we're open to ideas on ways that
you would want that kind of coverage you
just got to keep in mind like you know
we're the smallest company on the street
and like whenever our resources kind of
all go into one place I mean that's it
we can't we can't really do anything
else right and it's we also have in the
pipeline a few more videos on the last
Jedi that we found some new interesting
things about that movie that we want to
we want to discuss and break down but
for now let's come some time for a
15-second shout out each of us says 15
seconds to shut up plug ramble about
anything we want Sam why don't you start
yes we talked about it before the show
started and I'm blanking on what it was
and it was a I don't remember
oh no it's but yeah I got
we'll come back to you the great is yeah
I'll go ahead okay for me I want to plug
13 second dark on Netflix it's a it's a
German series but they have American or
English subtitles and dub it's kind of
like a mix of stranger things meets twin
peaks' small town where kids go missing
it's great yeah I want to plug what
happened in Monday
it's a Netflix movie sci-fi dystopian
future the idea is that you can no
longer have more than one child in this
society um so if you do they like put
them away and they freeze them until the
time when we get the resources to
sustain more children but unfortunately
one person has septuplets oh I and they
try to pass them all off as the same
person and one of them goes missing Wow
their names are Monday Susie Jacqueline
every 2 p.m. you get for second I
remember I remembered it's um oh the
trailer for altered carbon it's a new
Netflix series like that starring Joel
Kinnaman who everyone's favorite Rick
Flagg and Suicide Squad and I believe
the premise is immortality is now
achievable because we download our
brains into new bodies if you're rich if
you're rich and you can also like add
new attributes to those bodies like I
think and get muscle memory and I it's
the Joel Kinnaman character just got
down into a new body the three hundred
years in the future he's been frozen for
that long and not used and so now he has
to try to solve the murder of someone
who is alive because they got down into
a new body about how they got murdered
before I believe that's what the premise
is and it's like blade runner-esque
future but like I think they tone it
down just a little bit make it a little
gritty er it looks like another swing it
like like a big franchise for Netflix
kind of like a stranger honestly it's
really likely that that is going to be
our next big show like that we're all
gonna obsess over and breakdown and cake
down please more cake downs I would love
to do a culture Carbon cave all right
well let's return to our trivia question
that we asked earlier and
to remind everyone of what it was okay
what alias did Natasha Romanov used when
she first met Tony Stark I embedded as a
legal notary in his company in Iron Man
2 we have our answer card over there but
before we reveal it let's go down the
line and Philip wrote pepper knots all
the pots sam says sadie hawkins or Jane
bond these cases Tony's gonna pick up
spy all right all right Eric Grill
Ashley Mansfield is wait is that the
website for people like guys I want to
cheat on their way Madison I think it's
a girl I had a crush on in grade school
it's been since we have a Star Wars
trailer Ashley it's only 48 months away
is Natalie rushman Natalie rushman which
I guess Jane bond with Jane bond and
then who was the furthest one was yours
again you wrote pepper knocking okay so
the road as a winner all do our
good-byes and as our but first we got a
run through our in other news headlines
we didn't have time for but there's
still important that we want you to know
about them and Phillip as the loser as
decided by our judges of our trivia
question you will have to read these
headlines at the end of each headline
you have to make a joke
cleverly riff on it all right here we go
the release date of the upcoming x-men
movie New Mutants was moved for
this April back to February 2019 oh wow
this summer's Deadpool - has been moved
up two weeks from June to may 18th
aiming for more Memorial Day weekend
viewers so if you want to know what's
not gonna do well then check something
out in February 2019 when you got pushed
back a whole year bazinga
is because the gambit movie is now
coming out February 14th 2019 and it
just lost a Gore Verbinski as director
due to scheduling issues making him the
third director to leave the project but
the first director to be available now
on Valentine's Day February 14th he
could be your Mon Ami and movie theaters
in China have completely abandoned the
last Jedi it's just not doing well there
are they dumped 92 percent of its
screenings in the country after the
movie had underperformed there but so
luckily 8 percent of screenings are
still gonna result in 4 percent people
really pissed and 4 percent people
really apologizing for it a lot
Batman solo film director Matt Reeves
confirmed he has the story worked out
and he is currently outlining but that a
script still hasn't been finished also
has been finished Ben Affleck as Batman
Oh can't stop won't stop he's really
excited and finally a game of Thrones
themed Ice Hotel has opened in Finland
ins as happen years ago between large
ice sculptures of dry dragons and White
Walkers looming over lobbies and
bedrooms so nothing sets the mood like
an ice Sambi sitting in that room then I
actually Mansfield I don't know how Eric
is ever gonna win you over you know give
it some thought goodbye partners thank
you for watching this week's episode of
new rock stars knows this is just the
kind of now I have my - hey it's a
cowboy hey I want to thank our house
saying basher saying basher Eric you
said this is what you get for winning we
have to get put through this yeah
partner that's what you get for losing
comment down below and share it around
subscribe to thank you we're gonna rock
stars for all the deep dives and stuff
you love guys thank you for let me do
that no I won't do it again oh you see
next week